hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video für den titel wahrscheinlich
erstmal sowohl den wurde alles geklaut
was fünf scheiße modell passt denn es
ist nicht so unfassbar krass wie es sich
anhört aber ich wollte einfach mal so
ein paar stories von tumoren erzählen wo
ich ja die letzten wie langweilig da
gerade ist mittwoch der 27 juli um dich
war dort vom 22 juli also den freitag
letzter woche bis zum 25 juli also dem
montag vorgestern das war die zeit wo
ich in brüssel witzigerweise in belgien
da brüstet ist ja in belgien also daher
schon die wesentlichen sachen zu klären
etwa land ist ein idm festival wo
elektronischen dance musik gespielt wird
alles in richtung techno trap dubstep am
meisten allerdings haus progressive
future und ja man einfach wird von
vielen das festival der welt beschrieben
weil alle eigentlich total nett
zueinander sein auslandsamtes gestalten
die uns irgendwie voll viele sachen
abgezockt haben aber dazu komme ich
jetzt gleich wir sind auf jeden fall am
freitag hingefahren am mittag das war
mit einem kumpel von mir nahm tobias und
einer freundin von mir namens carola wir
feiern halt alle diese mucke und dann
bin ich halt mit dem auto am freitag hin
gefahren mit denen wir waren dann
irgendwann mittags da im hotel und
hatten halten hotel in brüssel und das
festival ist
sofort her gesehen hier ist brüssel hier
ist deutschland und da ist das festival
gewesen und war mir an dem freitag halt
angekommen im hotel sind eingecheckt und
waren dann irgendwie so um 15 16 uhr auf
dem hotelzimmer haben dann schon langsam
angefangen sofort zu trinken so ein
bisschen bier und so was in die richtung
das festival gegen jeden tag schon um 12
uhr los und endete halt immer irgendwann
nachts um zwölf oder ein uhr und wir
waren halt sogar erst um 15 16 uhr im
hotel und wandern halt dementsprechend
erst um 18 uhr oder 17 18 uhr auf dem
festival überhaupt tabu sein hotel über
gerufen
sie tanzen besser wir hingefahren war
dann halt dort und übel krass ist iti
leute man hat gemerkt dass das die das
ist das da war ich muss mich halt
ausziehen nur um da reinzukommen
wir waren auf jeden fall an dem montag
auf dem festivalgelände irgendwie so um
18.19 uhr sind dann halt direkt runter
gegangen die mainstage muss wissen es
gibt irgendwie gefüllt 700 millionen 63
stage es dort und auf jeder stage wird
eine andere mutter gespielt wobei jeder
stage stehen locker zehn millionen leute
so weil das sind einfach zu viele
menschen und da muss man natürlich kann
es auch seine sachen aufpassen haben wir
uns auch gedacht haben wir auch gemacht
trotzdem wird uns was geklaut dann wisst
ihr zum hintergrund gestanden bei der
mainstage weil wir wollten unbedingt ich
weiß nicht ob es die vbb es dabei you
double you oder dimitri vegas und leicht
war
ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher bei
welchen weg das war wie stand und in der
mainstage waren relativ weit vorne
wollten halt einfach nur dämpfen und so
entstanden da haben sie gefeiert und ich
natürlich berlin meines laptops oder an
den tag gesehen habt wisst ihr
wahrscheinlich dass ich da eigentlich so
die ganze zeit nahezu fast alle nur im
film war bei dem fest die begabten
cashless per system genauso wie letztes
jahr auch schon da hatte man einfach so
ein bändchen und konnte über das
bändchen einfach so bezahlen das heißt
man musste kein bargeld mehr
man musste keine karte mit dem man
musste versuchen dieses berlin mitnehmen
personalausweis wir drei er natürlich
auch noch ein handy mitgenommen weil
wenn man bei tumor land ist und sich
verliert und so da muss man sich
natürlich irgendwie verständigung man
will ja auch was ihnen die posten und
bilder machen und so was alles in die
richtung und dann hat der dj bei dem wir
waren auf einmal so ein richtig geiles
lied gespielt und wir dachten uns alle
drei sorten drop auf und jetzt auf
einmal so viel alle springen so hoch
räumlich legal ich habe genau ein video
gemacht am freitag um 17.30 da schreiten
wir nämlich anscheinend doch statt in
der mainstage sehe ich gerade bei dem
video konnte die gerade zwei sachen
sehen erstens wir standen relativ weit
vorne und zweitens um uns herum waren
übel viele menschen ich weiß nicht wie
viele leute insgesamt rollen sind aber
mir kampf verfolgt wer die halbe welt da
gewesen jedenfalls kam dieser druck ich
hab ihn gefilmt mit cnet gepostet und
dann auf einmal so toby leben wir so
ewiger wo ist mein handy und wir dachten
uns nur so alter wird es uns gerade
verarschen im ist wissen tobis sondern
manager hat sogar als wir auf dem weg zu
räumen war extra ein portemonnaie bei
mir zu hause gelassen damit er sein
portemonnaie nicht verliert und was
macht am ersten tag nach zwei stunden
festival fan hin nie verlieren und in
der handy hülle war auch noch sein
bargeld daran irgendwie 100 euro drin
oder so wir hatten halt alle ein iphone
6 s und haben quasi das geld so hinter
dieser hülle hier geklemmt also hülle
einfach aufgeklappt geld dahinter
geklemmt und einmal das geld entweder
man hat ich weiß nur das handy und
dieses armband ich hatte auch noch einen
jutebeutel mit aber da waren nur
taschentücher unseren tobi meine dann
auf jeden fall so während im job die
ganze liga wo ist mein handy ich kann
das nicht finden nicht so jahr hier ich
guck mal meine leute drehen so tage
kommt bei carola der tasche trug keine
ahnung und irgendwie haben wir das
unseren bislang fallen zu lachen sache
torri hat sein handy verloren oder zwei
sekunden später carola und ich haben
gerade so gelacht über tobi und hobby
war total fertig und dann sagt carol auf
einmal so guckt in ihrer tasche sagt wo
ist denn mein handy und ich dachte mir
nur so alter oder hab ich gemacht und ab
diesem zeitpunkt hatte ich mein handy
jeden tag nur noch so in der hand
festgehalten
ich hab's fast erdrückt zur galerie
festgehalten wir wollten dann alle auf
jeden fall tobis handy filmen und auch
carola sandy und
wir standard relativ weit vorne habe ich
ja schon gesagt da stand unter viele
menschen um einen drogen ich habe dann
alles so ein bisschen so weggeschubst so
von wegen hastings smartphone mit slogan
sonst darf und dann haben die halt
weggeschoben und da kann so ein schwede
zudem schob sich so zurück so ewer
schubst du nicht also auf schwedisch
also wahrscheinlich hat er das gesagt
aber er hat mich beleidigt oder wollte
pizza bestellen oder so und dann wurde
ich auch leicht aggressiv und habe ihm
dann auch geschubst eine krasse nummer
also wir haben das direkt geklärt so ein
kumpel kam am ende dann so hielt er hat
sein handy verloren und die wollen dass
so viel und er dann auch ja alles in
ordnung also überhaupt keine gewalt am
start gewesen aber werden anhalt auf
jeden fall will guckt bei dem boden der
boden war voll mit scheiße weil
irgendwie scheiße von dixi klo daher
geleitet wurde das war auch sehr schön
wie habt ihr das auf jeden fall gesucht
gesucht gesucht nichts gefunden dann
weggegangen haben uns noch mit daggi und
eugen getroffen wobei dessen ständen
saßen wir dann und dann haben carola und
wo wir erst mal von meinem handy
aussehen die vodafone group ceo ihr
wisst ihr wie ich handy orten kann oder
so mit der iphone apps hat nicht
geklappt und dann haben wir das hat auf
jeden fall auch nach zwei stunden
hingekriegt damit gesperrt gelöscht also
das wird uns am ersten tag geklaut der
zweite tag war dann eigentlich völlig in
ordnung also das letzte gegen einen vom
freitag bis samstag bis sonntag das
heißt am zweiten tag war wirklich alles
easy wir haben halt wieder getrunken
waren feiern und so beim passen zu hause
das busshuttle erwischt haben passenden
hotel gelegen am sonntag dann auch noch
gefrühstückt und sind dann halt wieder
mit einem ufer zum festival gelände
gefahren und an dem sonntag habe ich
dann gedacht okay letzter tag ich wollte
es nicht am ersten tag machen weil ich
sie dann wahrscheinlich verlieren werde
da habe ich mir dann halte die moral in
flagge gekauft ich blende euch jemanden
foto ein wie die ganze flagge quasi
haben wir aus sagte dass ein foto von
instagram dienstag ran da kommst du
ich habe ihn kurz vor eine million
dollar also check hat allemal aus ich
habe mir diese flagge dar anhalt gekauft
irgendwie so für 30 perlen das waren
umgerechnet 45 euro oder mit der planke
getanzt und bilder gemacht und am ende
des tages waren wir beide ich muss mal
ein bisschen durch 2 17 minuten der
overtime ende des tages waren wir damit
bei glaub ich die mega strike auf der
mainstage und da habe ich dann halt so
andere leute aus deutschland
kennengelernt wir waren jeden tag
bedanken unterwegs aber zu dem zeitpunkt
haben wir die beiden erstmal schon
verloren weil wir waren vorher mit den
noch im riesenrad und so aber ich hab
dann auf jeden fall da muss ein kreis
gemacht um so alle miteinander spielen
und da habe ich dann auch noch carola
und tobi verloren und war dann quasi
komplett alleine mit diesen deutschen
leute nicht controller sowie ja auch
nicht erreichen weil beide kein handy
mit hatten und mein akku war komplett
alle das habt ihr vielleicht wird ihr
bestes chat folgt gesehen dass am
letzten tag wichtig die story auf einmal
geändert hat irgendwie als es gerade
dunkel wurde war ein akku einfach leer
weil ich so viel weiss net war
jedenfalls habe ich dann halt mit diesen
leuten david schild und auf einmal roger
moore land vorbei und es war dann
irgendwie wirklich schon so behalt 1 1
uhr sa so und wir waren halt wirklich
alle ich sage einfach so nicht betrunken
aber auf einem guten level und die leute
haben also gesagt okay wir sind alle im
dream will welt und will spend bei uns
und ich habe mir gedacht ja ich muss
halt ich hab eigentlich ein hotel
gebucht in brüssel was ultra geil war
aber ich hatte keine ahnung wie ich zu
dem shuttle komme und vista wolle der
letzte tag vorbei strömen alle lotter
von dem festivalgelände und wind ich bin
auf jeden fall mit denen mit zu diesem
dreamworks dream will müsst ihr wissen
ist so ein ort wo die leute die beim
rollen sind kämpfen
also die leute die in die kein hotel
gekriegt haben oder einfach nur kämpfen
wollen und nicht mit hotel das ganze
verbinden wollte
man denkt halt dream will ok in den
raster wie sieht das mal sogar das
direkt neben abwehr ich bin bis dahin
irgendwie 30 35 minuten gelaufen auf dem
weg zu diesem bild habe ich dann
einerseits die leute verloren die ich
kennengelernt habe andererseits auch
irgendwie meine flagge die mir da
irgendwie abgezockt wurde von irgendwem
das weiß ich alles gar nicht mehr so
genau aber ich bin auf jeden fall im
nächsten morgen ohne flagge aufgefallen
und jetzt müsst ihr euch das mal so
vorstellen da ist luca hat keinen akku
an seinem handy hat seine flagge nicht
mehr hat außerdem nur noch 20 euro
bargeld mit weil wir haben jeden tag
immer so wenig wie möglich bargeld
mitgenommen dass in die hülle gepackt
irgendwo in dieser scheiß kleinstadt
name ist boom in belgien wo das treffen
stattfindet was nicht mehr stattgefunden
hat das war dann vorbei ich habe
deutsche kennengelernt die mich
verlassen habe und meine flagge
abgezogen haben ich habe das shuttle zu
meinem hotel verpasst was vor einer
stunde zu dem zeitpunkt da gefahren ist
und ich stehe da irgendwo kenne keinen
hat kein geld kein abo kannten sogar
wenn ich ab jetzt vor unklar oder nicht
erreichen kann weil ich keine nummer von
nie gehabt hätte weil die ja keinen
handy hatten was hat sich da luca
gedacht er geht erst mal zum lost and
found stand und dann stand ich halt da
denn wie zehn minuten angestanden und
danach die frau so gehört hey ich
eineinhalb judith collins erlebt wegen
und dann habe ich also gesagt hey ja ich
habe meine freunde verloren
dann hat die sich über mich lustig
gemacht habe dann reden wir vom
gebrochenen englisch guckt mal hinten ob
die kleider abgegeben hat und euch
ausgedacht alter täglich wissen dass wir
für einen scheiß stand sorgt sie konnte
mir einfach nicht richtig weiterhelfen
aber noch rum gestand hat die von der
bahn also ich die blöde kuh die ganze
crew hilf mir doch das war schon witzig
was ich da so für andere story
aufgegriffen habe da waren so andere
leute sind so hingegen meinten so joel
osment und sogar selbst auf total
beschissen in englisch irgendwie so
konnte ich gar nicht verständigen und
ich weiß vettel das war vor der typ ist
bayern kommt zurück zu seinem
campingplatz oder ein komplettes feldes
geklaut
ich will gar nicht mehr so lange jetzt
hier weiter reden aber die story endete
dann auf jeden fall so dass ich nach 20
minuten ein taxifahrer gefunden habe der
mich mitnehmen wollte und nicht direkt
gesagt ja ich hab mit bargeld nicht
dabei ich habe aber ein hotel gebucht
wenn wir im hotel so könnt ihr direkt
nach oben gehen ich geb dir bargeld ab
150 euro bezahlt für ein scheiß taxi
also wenn man zone und habe ich ca jeden
tag und mit der taxifahrt zusammen so
viel geld bezahlt wie die anderen
bezahlt haben was ihr handy kostet was
sie verloren haben also in einer
gewissen form haben wie jeder irgendwie
ein iphone 6 wert verloren
an dieser stelle würde ich das video
software and meine damen und herren das
hört sich jetzt mal so kaka an aber das
festival war geil ich will seitdem im
peiner land club mehr geben ist es echte
wenn man einmal auf einem richtig gern
festival war einfach normale party aber
keinen spaß mehr ich hoffe euch hat
diese story tolle sache hier heute abend
also ein bisschen gefallen ich wollte
halt einfach mal so ein paar sachen
loswerden die bei dem festival passierte
ist noch viel mehr passiert dann
zwischendurch eugen verlages freuen wir
haben diesen in diesem riesenrad da
gemacht hat umgesprungen gottes hand so
halb abgestürzt oder so es sind ultra
witzige sachen passiert ich wollte es
aber nochmal so die krassesten
ereignisse hier zusammen fassen ich
hoffe euch als gängige fire es getan
habe ich schon gesagt dass ihren daumen
hoch verlassen soll ich weiß es nicht
allein machen so story tatsachen und
ranzig spaß ist vielleicht in ruhe
lassen ich nehme jetzt auf einem bett
man sieht mein schädel immer noch